>> Jon: GOOD TIME NOT TO BE
LIVING IN SEATTLE.
THANKS VERY MUCH, DAN SPRINGER.
>> I DON’T BELIEVE THIS IS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUE.
WE ARE SO BUSY ENFORCING AND
KEEPING OUR CITIZENS SAFE BY
ARRESTING ROBBERS AND CHILD
MOLESTERS AND HOME BURGLARS.
MAKING CRIMINALS OUT OF
NORMALLY LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
>> Sandra: FRESNO COUNTY,
CALIFORNIA SHERIFF ON THIS
PROGRAM YESTERDAY.
SHE JOINED SEVERAL OTHER
SHERIFFS ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO
ARE REFUSING TO ENFORCE COVID
RESTRICTIONS LIKE LOCKDOWNS AND
CURFEWS THIS HOLIDAY SEASON.
TOM HOMAN A FORMER DIRECTOR OF
ICE AND THANKS FOR BEING HERE
THIS MORNING.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE SHERIFFS
GOING AT IT ON THEIR OWN SAYING
WE AREN’T GOING TO ENFORCE THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THEY ARE GREAT AMERICAN
PATRIOTS.
THEY UNDERSTAND LAW ABIDING
U.S. CITIZENS HAVE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS, TOO.
THESE GOVERNORS AND DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS THINK THAT PROTESTS
TURNED VIOLENT AND TELL THE
POLICE TO TURN A BLIND EYE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO GATHER AND
PETITION THE GOVERNMENT, THEY
HAVE THAT RIGHT.
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS DON’T HAVE
A FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO GO
TO CHURCH OR HAVE FAMILY
GATHERINGS?
I THINK THESE SHERIFFS ARE
AMERICAN PATRIOTS AND GOD BLESS
THEM.
>> Sandra: WEIGH IN ON THE
BROADER PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A RISING INFECTION RATE
HAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE’VE GOT HOSPITALIZATION RATE
GOING UP AS WELL.
DEATHS ARE CLIMBING IN NUMBERS.
THERE IS A HUGE PROBLEM WITH
THE PANDEMIC AND COVID-19 IN
THE COUNTRY.
MANY OF THESE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES ARE TRYING TO DO
THEIR BEST TO FORCE
RESTRICTIONS TO STOP THE SPREAD.
YOU MAY AGREE WITH THEM OR NOT
AGREE WITH THEM.
WEIGH IN ON IT.
HOW SHOULD IT BE HANDLED?
>> LOOK, I THINK THE CDC MADE
IT CLEAR.
I THINK WEARING MASKS WHEN IT’S
APPROPRIATE IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
SOCIAL DISTANCING WHEN
APPROPRIATE IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
WHAT THE GOVERNORS HAVE DONE,
THERE IS NO LAW THAT HAS BEEN
ENACTED BY A LEGISLATURE.
THEY JUST DECIDE TO MAKE A
DECISION.
AND THEY WANT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUT THERE TO ENFORCE A NON-LAW
AGAINST U.S. CITIZENS BUT
REFUSE TO LET THE SAME LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WORK WITH
ICE TO ARREST PEOPLE AROUND
THEIR JAIL WHICH IS THEIR JOB
TO KEEP CRIMINALS LOCKED UP AND
KEEP OUR STREETS SAFE.
THEY REFUSE THAT.
IT IS HYPOCRISY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN’T DO THE JOB
UNLESS PROTESTORS COMMIT CRIMES
OR WORK WITH ICE TO TAKE PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS OFF THE STREET.
THAT’S A NO-GO FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS.
THEY CAN’T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
THEY CAN’T SAY ENFORCE THIS
AGAINST LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
AND ESTIMATE IGNORE CRIMINAL
STATUTES THAT WAS LEGISLATED BY
EITHER CONGRESS OR STATE
LEGISLATURE.
>> Sandra: AS YOU WELL KNOW
ANDREW CUOMO IN NEW YORK
DOESN’T AGREE WITH YOU.
LISTEN.
>> HOW A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER SAYS I CHOOSE NOT TO
ENFORCE THAT LAW, I BELIEVE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
VIOLATES HIS OR HER
CONSTITUTIONAL JOB AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
THAT’S A DICTATOR.
SO YOU ARE NOT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
YOU CAN’T PICK AND CHOOSE.
AND IF THAT’S THE WAY YOU RUN
YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY I
DON’T CONSIDER IT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTZ.
>> Sandra: IF THE SHERIFFS
DON’T ABIDE, MANY OF THEM WHO
HAVE SAID THAT, TOM, COULD THEY
BE HELD RESPONSIBLE BY
GOVERNORS LIKE ANDREW CUOMO?
>> FIRST OF ALL LET’S BE CLEAR.
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS STATING
MISFACTS THERE.
LYING TO HIS PEOPLE.
THERE IS NO LAW.
NO LAW WAS ENACTED BY HIS STATE
LEGISLATURE.
IF ANYBODY IS A DICTATOR IT’S
HIM.
I’LL SAY THE SAME THING TO
GOVERNOR CUOMO THAT I SAID IN
MY LAST HEARING.
I PAY A LOT OF TAXES IN NEW
YORK.
HE WORKS FOR ME.
HE WORKS FOR THE NEW YORK STATE
TAXPAYERS.
HE IS ACCOUNTABLE TO US NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND.
WE AREN’T ACCOUNTABLE TO HIM.
SO TO HIM VILIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR PROTECTING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS FOR NEW
YORK STATE RESIDENTS IS
ABHORRENT.
IT IS INSULTING THAT A GOVERNOR
WOULD SAY THAT.
>> Sandra: LET’S LOOK AT SOME
OF THE RESTRICTIONS.
THE QUARANTINE RESTRICTIONS HE
HAS PUT IN PLACE FOR HIS STATE
THAT ARE VERY STRICT, MUCH
STRICTER FOR ANY OTHER STATE
WAS ISSUED BY EXECUTIVE ORDER.
>> YEAH, I GET THAT.
BUT THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS
NOT ENACTED ANY LAWS IN THE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
LOOK, THE PROBLEM IS IT’S
INCONSISTENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NEW YORK STATE GOVERNOR CUOMO
HAS BEENVILLE FILING LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR YEARS.
IT ISN’T JUST COVID.
HE HAS BEEN ATTACKING ICE
OFFICERS AND COMPARED THEM TO
THE GANGSTERS ON THE STREET.
HE WON’T ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN NEW YORK TO WORK
WITH ICE.
HIM ALONG WITH THE MAYOR OF NEW
YORK CITY DEBLASIO HAS KNOCKED
ICE OUT OF THE RYKER’S ISLAND
JAIL.
LET’S NOT GET THINGS MIXED UP
WITH GOVERNOR CUOMO.
HE HAS BEEN AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM DAY ONE
ANDVILLE FILING THEM FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THIS IS JUST HIS LATEST
ARGUMENT WHY LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
LESS THAN THEY USED TO BE.
>> Sandra: AS WE LISTEN TO WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING AND TAKE THAT IN
AND HEARD WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
TO SAY AND OTHER DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO HAVE TOUGH RESTRICTIONS ON
THEIR PEOPLE, YOU SEE AND YOU
SAY THAT YOU BELIEVE THE CDC
AND SCIENCE AND SAYS TO WEAR A
MASK, SOCIAL DISTANCE.
IF THAT ISN’T GOING ON AND THAT
CERTAINLY ISN’T GOING ON IN
SOME AREAS OF THE COUNTRY.
WE DON’T LIKE TO THINK SO BUT
IT IS.
SHOULD SOMETHING BE DONE AT A
LOCAL OR STATE LEVEL TO HELP
ENFORCE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE KNOW SIGNIFICANTLY SLOW OR
STOP THE SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS?
SHOULD ANYTHING BE DONE TO
ENFORCE THAT?
>> MAYBE A STATE OFFICIAL CAN
ENFORCE IT.
WHAT HE IS ASKING SOMEONE TO
DO, HE IS ASKING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ENFORCE
SOMETHING THAT ISN’T A LAW.
IF HE WANTS TO SEND DOWN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER, YOU CAN’T TELL
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ENFORCE A
LAW THAT HASN’T BEEN ENACTED BY
ANY STATE LEGISLATURE AND
ATTACK LAW ABIDING CITIZENS AND
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AT
THE SAME TIME TELLING THEM YOU
AREN’T ALLOWED TO ARREST
PROTESTORS OR HELP ICE.
YOU CAN’T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> Sandra: THERE WAS A LARGE
JEWISH WEDDING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
HE IS WARNING LEGAL ACTION
AGAINST THIS.
A LOT OF THESE STATES ARE
FACING IT NOW AS WE ALL TRY TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING IT.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THIS
MORNING.
DID YOU HAVE A FINAL THOUGHT?
>> NO, I THINK AT SOME POINT WE
NEED TO TRUST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
COVID-19 I’M NOT BELITTLING IT.
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE WE’RE
DEALING WITH.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS HAVE DIED
AND IT IS SERIOUS.
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO LET
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TAKE
CONTROL OF THEIR LIVES.
MOST CITIZENS WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING.
FOR THOSE THAT DON’T WE’LL HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN’T VIOLATE THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS, TOO.
WHILE PROTECTING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE COMMITTING CRIMES.
IT IS JUST NOT THE WAY THIS